Atika popular youtuber and streamer has
been found dead after missing for nearly
a week
Atika whose real name is Desmond went
missing on June 19th after uploading an
8 minute long video titled I'm sorry
that appeared to be a goodbye shouldn't
push the many people who were the video
which has since been deleted by YouTube
contained a lengthy description that
read in part I'm sorry I never sought
help for myself my time ends now but if
there is a way for me to I'll send you
all as many blessings as I can from the
other side following the video on June
20th the NYPD shared they were looking
for Etica On June 22nd the New York Post
reported his personal belongings were
found along Manhattan Bridge on the
evening of June 24th police discovered a
body in Manhattan's East River
the NYPD tweeted On June 25th we regret
to inform that Desmond aka Etica has
been found deceased his cause of death
is unknown at this time
the online community began sharing
condolences including his former
girlfriend Alice who tweeted I want his
funeral to be as big as his personality
his heart and his spirit I loved him
he is finally at peace Atticus struggles
became a major concern for fans over the
past year no go home I don't want to
open the door in April police detained
him over mental health concerns which he
streamed on Instagram live in May he
returned to YouTube with a new channel
do I have to explain necessarily what
happened I missed out on so many things
while I was gone in my my little hiatus
is - who you know where Attica began
creating videos in 2012 and was best
known for his reaction and gaming
related videos what's going on guys
Attica from the edeka world network here
if you or someone you know is struggling
please call the National Suicide
Prevention lifeline
you